well it seemed inevitable but now mike  lindell the my pillow guy has joined the  ranks of people like sydney powell and  rudy giuliani who are being sued for  billions of dollars related to alleged  defamation damages  related to all the crazy things that  they were saying about the elections  i've done lots of videos on how crazy  all of these things were but it's no  surprise that dominion  one of the makers of these election  related machines has sued mike lindell  for a huge amount of damages that they  have allegedly suffered to their  business and reputation  pro tip for anyone that is thinking  about committing defamation against  other people or businesses  maybe don't create a whole documentary  called absolute proof where you document  all of the crazy nonsensical things that  you  want to say that are allegedly  defamatory but that you know hashtag not  legal advice  but anyway subscribe or i'll see you in  court especially if you're mike lindell